another football player arrested in las
vegas today former nfl running back
marshawn lynch taken into custody just
this morning on suspicion of dui sports
director chris matthews joining us in
studio with all the details chris well
thank you guys according to police lynch
was seen driving erratically in a
neighborhood north of the stratosphere
this morning police say he was driving
into curbs and not using travel lanes
near fairfield avenue and west utah
which is a few blocks north of sahara
and the stratosphere resort authorities
suspected driver impairment and during
their investigation concluded that the
five-time pro bowl running back was
driving under the influence so they
arrested and transported lynch to the
las vegas city jail where he was booked
for dui and driving an unregistered
vehicle he's due back in municipal court
on december 7th his bail was set at 3
300
as of right now he is still in jail less
than 24 hours ago the former seattle and
raiders running back signed a contract
with the seattle seahawks as a special
correspondent he was hired to do some
creative projects with the team now this
is the third time he's had a run-in with
the law in 2008 he pled guilty to a hit
and run in buffalo then in 2012 the 36
year old was arrested for dui in
california and later pled guilty to
reckless driving in 2014. now less than
a month ago lynch invited by the raiders
to play in the battle for vegas charity
softball game between the raiders and
the golden knights like all the athletes
at that event he was one of the more
popular and he has appeared to have a
great time there he was one of the more
popular players on the raiders roster
while he played with the raiders now
lynch played two seasons with las vegas
before closing out his career in 2019 by
playing for seattle a second time he
also played with buffalo seattle and the
raiders over the course of his career
kirsten thank you very much